Jetzt ist es endlich untersucht. Während
eines spektakulären Außenbordeinsatzes wurde
das corpus delicti, also das Loch an der Außenhülle
der Sojus MS-09 näher untersucht. Es geht
um das Loch in der Sojushülle, das im Sommer
zu einem dramatischen Druckabfall an Bord
der Internationalen Raumstation, der ISS geführt
hatte. Was dort gefunden wurde und warum der
Weltraumeinsatz anders gelaufen ist, als geplant.
Jetzt in Clixoom Science & Fiction. Hier gibt
es täglich spannende Science-Videos. Abonniert
den Kanal. Dann verpasst ihr kein Video. Herzlich
willkommen.
Es war eine dramatische Situation im letzten
August an Borde der ISS. Es wurde ein Leck
in der Raumstation ISS festgestellt. Stück
für Stück wurden die Schots der Module geschlossen,
um den Ort der Undichtigkeit einzugrenzen.
Schließlich stieß die Besatzung auf ein
Loch in einer angedockten Sojus-Kapsel und
zwar genau der, mit der Alexander Gerst am
6. Juni zur ISS gestartet war. Erst wurde
ein Produktionsfehler, ein Meteroid oder ein
Riss vermutet. Doch ein ehemaliger Kosmonaut
meldete sich zu Wort. Maxim Surajew äußert
die sehr beunruhigende Vermutung, dass ein
Besatzungsmitglied hier sabotiert hat. Der
staatlichen Nachrichtenagentur RIA Novosti
sagte er, dass es nicht ausgeschlossen werden
könne, dass ein Besatzungsmitglied "diese
seltsame Nummer abgezogen hat. Wir sind alle
Menschen und jeder könnte nach Hause wollen".
Die NASA hatte die Aufnahme des Loches damals
aus dem Netz genommen, wohl weil sie ziemlich
erschreckend ist. Wir hatten sie wieder aus
dem Netz gefischt und so sah es damals aus.
Man sieht deutlich, dass bei der möglichen
, ich sage mal „Tat“, mehrfach versucht
wurde anzusetzen. Der Bohrer ist mehrere Male
abgerutscht bevor er dann griff und das Loch
bohrte. Die Besatzung fand das Loch dann und
nach Absprache mit russischen und amerikanischen
Fluglotsen wurde es von innen repariert, besser
gesagt gestopft. Der Astronaut Sergey Prokopyev
benutzte dazu ein Gaze Tuch und Epoxidharz.
Und das mit Erfolg. Seit der Reparatur konnte
der Druck aufrecht erhalten werden. Jetzt
wagten sich Die beiden Kosmonauten Oleg Kononenko
und Sergey Prokopyev von der russischen Raumfahrtagentur
Roskomsos sich nun aus der ISS zu dem bereits
von innen lokalisiertem Loch an der Außenhölle
der Sojus Sonde MS-09, welche an das Rassvet-Modul
im russischen Segment der Internationalen
Raumstation angedockt ist. "Es ist eine Herausforderung.
Sergej und ich nehmen sie an" sagte Kononenko
vor verlassen der ISS. Ziel der beiden Kosmonauten
war es, die Ursache der Lecks herauszufinden
und Proben des nun an der Aussenseite ausgetretenem
Epoxidharzes zu entnehmen. Um an das Loch
zu gelangen setzte sich Kononenko auf das
Ende eines Strela-Kranes während sein Kollege
Prokopyev am anderen Ende stand und ihn lenkte.
Schlussendlich wurde ein weiterer Ausleger
aufgebaut und Prokopyev erreichte ebenfalls
das Loch. Dort durchtrennten die beiden Kosmonauten
mit einem Messer sowie einer Langarmschere
Teile der braun-goldenen Isolierungsschicht
der Sojus Kapsel und entfernten Teile der
Isolierung und des Orbitalschutzschildes.
Materialreste flogen davon und bildeten kleine
Wolken aus Trümmern. “Das ist genau das
Loch, nach dem wir gesucht haben” berichtete
Kononenko nachdem sie die Schicht abgezogen
hatten, welche das Leck verdeckte. Mit Hilfe
einer Pinzette und einem Tupfer extrahierte
Kononenko schließlich Proben des dunklen
Epoxidharzes. Das ist genau das Harz, mit
dem das Loch von innen geflickt wurde. Diese
wurden sorgfältig verpackt und sollen für
eine Analyse nun zur Erde zurückgebracht
werden. “Lasst uns nicht hetzen. Lasst uns
Schritt für Schritt vorgehen um nichts zu
vermasseln.” sagte Kononenko während der
live übertragenen Mission. Der Ausseneinsatz
lief allerdings nicht wie geplant. Statt 6
Stunden benötigten die Kosmonauten fast acht.
Aufgrund der Länge des Spazierganges verzichteten
die Kosmonauten in Rücksprache mit den Fluglotsen
auf die Reparatur der offengelegten Stelle
mit einer Ersatzisolierdecke. Allerdings bedeutet
das keine Gefahr, denn das Orbitalteil an
dem sie gearbeitet hatten, wird bei Wiedereintritt
der Kapsel in die Erdatmosphäre abgeworfen
und wird beim Eintritt in die Erdatmosphäre
verglühen. Noch immer ist damit nicht klar,
wer diesen Schaden warum, wo, wie verursacht
hat. Wenn es dazu mehr Infos gibt erfahrt
ihr das natürlich hier. Wenn ihr euch für
noch mehr Science interessiert, dann schaut
auch mal beim Raumzeitvlog der Zukunft vorbei.
Dafür hier klicken! Und hier geht es direkt
weiter mit einem Video der Kollegen: „Das
Fermiparadoxon - Erste Antworten!“ Bis dann,
bleibt dran!
ABMOD
Quelle:
https://www.space.com/42705-cosmonauts-spacewalk-soyuz-spacecraft-hole.html
https://www.welt.de/newsticker/news1/article185379056/Weltraum-Kosmonauten-untersuchen-bei-heiklem-Weltraum-Ausseneinsatz-Loch-an-der-Sojus.html
https://www.heise.de/newsticker/meldung/Kosmonauten-untersuchen-Leck-bei-ISS-Ausseneinsatz-4248267.html
Sabotage auf der Internationalen Raumstation
ISS!
Das ist wirklich nicht gut. Auf der Internationalen
Raumstation ISS gab es offensichtlich einen
Akt der Sabotage. Das Leck, dass letzte Woche
aufgetaucht ist, wurde nicht durch einen Materialfehler
oder Einschlag eines Meteoriden verursacht,
sondern durch ein von einem Menschen gebohrtes
Loch. Wie bitte? Was ist passiert? Und was
sind vor allem die Konsequenzen? Clixoom Science
& Fiction. Herzlich willkommen!
Gar nicht gut, gar nicht gut! Was ist da oben
los? Und das Schlimme: Scheinbar scheint es
keiner so richtig zu wissen. Die Fakten: Vergangene
Woche Donnerstag wurde ein Leck in der Raumstation
ISS festgestellt. Stück für Stück wurden
die Schots der Module geschlossen, um den
Ort der Undichtigkeit einzugrenzen. Schließlich
stieß die Besatzung auf ein Loch in einer
angedockten Sojus-Kapsel und zwar genau der,
mit der Alexander Gerst am 6. Juni zur ISS
gestartet war, die Sojus ^. Erst wurde ein
Produktionsfehler, ein Meteroid oder ein Riss
vermutet. Doch was jetzt öffentlich wurde,
lässt einem das Blut in den Adern gefrieren.
Und das ist absolut keine Übertreibung. Ein
ehemaliger Kosmonaut hat sich dazu jetzt zu
Wort gemeldet. Maxim Surajew äußert die
sehr beunruhigende Vermutung, dass ein Besatzungsmitglied
hier sabotiert hat. Der staatlichen Nachrichtenagentur
RIA Novosti sagte er, dass es nicht ausgeschlossen
werden könne, dass ein Besatzungsmitglied
"diese seltsame Nummer abgezogen hat. Wir
sind alle Menschen und jeder könnte nach
Hause wollen". What? Die NASA hat die Aufnahme
des Loches inzwischen aus dem Netz genommen,
wohl weil sie ziemlich erschreckend ist. Wir
haben sie aus dem Netz gefischt und können
hier die wirklich schlimmen Details zeigen.
Man sieht deutlich, dass bei der Sabotage
mehrfach versucht wurde anzusetzen. Der Bohrer
ist mehrere Male abgerutscht bevor er dann
griff und das Loch bohrte. Die Besatzung fand
das Loch letzte Woche und konnte es mit Epoxidharz
und einem Tuch flicken. Roskosmos Direktor
Dimitri Rogosin wurde erst im Mai ernannt,
um Missstände beim Sojusprogramm zu beseitigen.
Jetzt ist es noch schlimmer. Diese Sabotage
macht Raumfahrt in Zukunft extrem unsicher.
Die Frage ist immer noch: Wer konkret hat
das getan? Die Spekulationen schießen in
den letzten Stunden ins Kraut. Raumfahrtjournalist
Eric Berger meint zu wissen, dass es Indizien
gäbe, dass der Schaden bereits auf der Erde
entstand. Er behauptet, dass ein Techniker
diesen “Bohrfehler” sah, mit Leim verschloss,
wodurch er bei Vakuumtests nicht auffiel.
Okay. Leim soll drei Monate Vakuum im Weltraum
standgehalten haben? Wo sind die Leimspuren?
Roskosmoschef Rogosin schließt Schlamperei
nicht aus, aber eben auch "eine andere Version,
die wir nicht ausschließen: eine absichtliche
Störung im Weltall". Auch Rogosin hat "mehrere
Versuche" festgestellt, ein Loch in die Sojus-Kapsel
zu bohren. Sie seien mit "zögerlicher Hand"
ausgeführt worden. Das ist wirklich gar keine
gute Situation. Und es spricht eigentlich
alles dafür, dass das Loch dort oben gebohrt
wurde. Was ist da oben also gerade los? Wie
soll der Täter gefunden werden? Was sind
die Konsequenzen? Muss das Sojusprogramm eingestellt
werden? Wird die Space X Dragon Crew-Kapsel
jetzt schneller zum Einsatz kommen? So etwas
ist wirklich eine absolute Katastrophe und
wenn es sich bewahrheitet, das erste Mal überhaupt,
dass im Weltall sabotiert wurde. Wir halten
euch hier auf dem Laufenden. Wenn ihr kein
Video dazu und zu allen anderen Themen verpassen
wollt, dann abonniert Clixoom, Glocke nicht
vergessen, dafür hier klicken - folgt mir
auf WhatsApp, da gibt es die Videos früher.
Dafür hier klicken! Keine Werbung mehr auf
Clixoom gibt es, wenn ihr Mitglied werdet.
Der Link ist unter dem Video. Wenn nicht,
mal am Computer anschauen. Und hier geht es
weiter mit: “Der Wettlauf ins Weltall”
Bis dann, bleibt dran!
Quellen
https://www.dw.com/de/loch-in-der-iss-sabotage-im-all-oder-schlamperei/a-45361657?maca=de-GK-Flipboard-DE-Wissen_und_Umwelt-21159-xml-media
https://arstechnica.com/science/2018/09/russian-space-chief-vows-to-find-full-name-of-technician-who-caused-iss-leak/
https://www.nasaspaceflight.com/2018/08/soyuz-station-leak-no-threat-repairs-continue/
Bitte zahlreiche Bilder verwenden. Beim Loch
das ganze Foto, dann ranzoomen und die Abrutschspuren
einkreisen
Video vom Docking der Sojus aus dem letzten
Link verwenden usw.
Es wurde vor kurzem ein Loch in der ISS entdeckt,
doch jetzt wird vermutet dass es ein mutwilliger
Akt der Sabotage an der Internationalen Raumstation
war! Wer hat das Leck in die Sojus-Kapsel
gebohrt, mit der Alexander Gerst an die Station
andockte! Alle Fakten jetzt hier!
Druckabfall ISS Sabotage, Druckabfall NASA,
Loch ISS, Loch Internationale Raumstation,
Druckabfall ISS, Sabotage ISS, Sabotage NASA,
Russland ISS Sabotage, Russland ISS, ISS loch
gebohrt, NASA loch flicken, Loch Raumschiff,
Leck ISS, Sabotage ISS, NASA Sabotage, Alexander
Gerst, Sojus Kapsel loch, Sojus MS-09, Sojus
Hole, NASA, Dimitri Rogosin, Unfälle Weltall,
Sabotage Astronaut,Raumfahrt, Roskosmo, Raumschiff
reparieren, Reparatur im All, Vakuum ISS,
ISS kaputt, ISS defekt, Dockingmodul,